merci le président merci madame le
président monsieur robert je fais un
petit rappel à l'ordre c'est madame la
présidente
c'est un rappel à l'ordre julie aubert
est un récidiviste en janvier dernier
déjà à la tribune il interpellait la
ministre de la sorte et des devoirs
madame le ministre adam le ministre cela
s'était terminé par un trait d'humour en
guise d'avertissement
monsieur le député vous étiez
la dernière oratrice inscrits cette fois
ci ça n'est pas passé messieurs aubert
merci madame j'en profite en
introduction puisque madame ça va pas
non plus vous m'avez mener c'est non non
non non non alors messieurs aubert
n'avait plus la parole soit vous
respectez la présidence de séance soyez
un problème mais je ressentais madame la
présidente je suis le terreau il ya un
rappel à l'ordre avec inscription au
procès verbal est un rappel à l'ordre
madame le président